I think we've covered most of the big things. Is there anything that you guys kind of working on now?
We have this queue system still and a lot of the actions, like doing a vote,
when you actually hit the APIN point, all it does is insert an item into the queue
and doesn't do any work on it and that happens in the background.
If one of the database is going slow and it's taking too long to write, it doesn't affect the user.
And we use that for a lot of stuff now, and we're trying to move more towards that.
The queuing architecture is nice. >>Yes. >>And you're using AMQP? >>Yeah.
And, we're using RabbitMQ when I left.
I remember just as I was leaving, I remember going this is a really nice architecture.
They should do more of this, so I'm glad to see that that's working out.